I know it's probably a tough subject but
like Robbie Coltrane when he when he
passed that's gotta that were you close
with him yeah he was he was he was the
definitely he was so ready and open
you know him you know I feel like it
took a lot longer sometimes with the
other adult actors to be like okay
they're down to like talk to us you know
Robbie was always like Hagrid you know
he's that like Uncle that you want to
have that like perfect teacher that kind
of someone to lean on just fun just like
lovely warm fun and you know just would
be like he had such good memory of like
you would tell him stories and he would
like remember them you know years later
and just really know you and get to know
everyone he was just a very loving
giving person